Here's a brand new idea
from the United States
which can turn your television set
into a game that two can play.
You ready, Jen? Play.
Pong, first released in 1972,
was as simple as a game
can possibly be.
Two white rectangles batting
a square ball back and forward
as players attempted to win
points off each other.
It tested reflexes and nerves
and introduced an exciting
new medium to millions.
Most importantly,
it turned pal against pal
or sibling against sibling
in a spot of friendly
or fierce competition.
That's something
the gaming industry is still doing
to the delight of millions
to this day.
Video games have come a long way
since Pong though.
Your mother thinks you ought to be
spending more time at your homework.
What do you think about that?
Undoubtably, yes.
This old stereotype
of gamers being isolated loners
is quite frankly boring and outdated.
Video games have long since
come out of the bedroom
and into the world.
Shared and celebrated
by fans and communities
across the globe.
Here are six more
of the iconic titles
that helped make that happen.
Around five years after Pong
Space Invaders was launched,
bringing with it more colours,
more sophisticated music
and a distinctive plot and mood.
While sceptics dismissed Pong
as a passing novelty
Space Invaders proved that video
games were not only here to stay
but they were a massive and
extremely profitable global industry.
And the little pixelated enemies
are still used to this day
as an icon of video games as a whole.
Waka-waka-ing his way
onto the scene in 1980,
Pac-man was arguably
video gaming's first real character.
Urban legend states that his shape
was inspired by a pizza
minus a couple of slices.
Pac-man tried something different.
In it you had to use your wits
and strategically evade enemies
until you were strong enough
to chase them down instead.
Pac-man quickly became
a pop culture phenomenon
featuring on t-shirts,
ties, glasses, bags,
balloons, board games, books, caps
and any other merchandise that
sat around in one spot for too long.
Of all the video game characters
to grace our consoles over the years,
none have made an impact
quite like Mario.
The side-scrolling platform game
featured a plumber
trying to rescue a princess
from a fire-breathing turtle
and a labyrinth of pipes
and platforms to traverse
while avoiding razor-toothed plants
and even odder-looking mushrooms.
And so of course
it captured gamers' hearts
and became one of the fastest-selling
video games of all time.
Tomb Raider was the butt-kicking,
action-adventure game
that sold PlayStation consoles
by the bucketload
and introduced the world to fictional
archaeologist/treasure hunter
Lara Croft.
As one of the first ever
notable female game protagonists
Lara's Launch in 1996 had already
caused a media sensation.
If Pac-man was
gaming's first ever character
and Mario its first mascot,
Lara Croft was its first icon.
Now you could argue that Lara
is really more a source of male
titillation than female empowerment
but she was one of the first
playable women
I remember seeing in a video game
and that representation
really mattered.
World of Warcraft, launched in 2004,
still stands as one of the biggest
massively multiplayer online
role playing games of all time.
Players could create an avatar,
assign them a class, race and skills
and then send them out into
the world of Azeroth to explore,
complete quests and meet
with other player characters.
In its prime, the game had more
than 100 million registered users.
World of Warcraft played a huge role
in legitimising multiplayer
gaming for the masses.
And I should know,
I spent six years on it.
Minecraft is an open world game
that lets players build, create
and alter environments
by making, placing
and destroying blocks.
It's been extremely popular
with children and academics alike
due to its incredible scope
for creating physics
and logic-based puzzles
and to scale replicas of everything
from the Starship Enterprise
to the British Isles.
A large part of its popularity is
that it's an incredibly social game
with a litany of devoted fans
who work together to build entire
worlds out of little coloured blocks.
Of course, there were many other
titles that changed the world
over gaming's long
and lustrous history.
In the last decade the rise of indie
games, esports and mobile games
have changed
the gaming landscape again,
as players themselves diversify
and look for new experiences
they can share with other players.
Fans have known this for a long time
that video games aren't just games -
they're art, they're fun,
they're beautiful.
They can amaze, delight,
teach, empathise, empower.
They're a huge part of our culture
and they're here to change the world.
Thanks for watching! :)
Don’t forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos. See you again soon!